- What's going on, I'm
Yungblud from the UK,
and I've been traveling
across America with Buzzfeed
and with Vans Warped Tour.
I'm from a place called Doncaster
in the North of England.
I've been recording
videos; so far I've made
beans on toast in a strip club,
eaten seafood in Long Island,
I'm going all across America
trying out foods from your country.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Lemon pepper wings.
A southern tradition.
Magic City classic.
- They look incredible.
(upbeat music)
That's the best (bleep)
chicken wing I've ever had.
I ain't even lying.
Holy (bleep).
They are (bleep) gorgeous, man.
Bruv, I love the crispy skin and (bleep).
Adam.
Come here.
Eat that in the window.
Alright, they gave me a well nice meal
at Magic City in Atlanta,
so I'm gonna ask the chef if
I can make him beans on toast.
A little something from where I'm from.
Proper, (bleep) British beans on toast.
Right nice, try it out bruv.
(upbeat music)
Good innit?
(Yungblud laughing)
Yes, bro!
(Bleep) yeah!
- It's good.
- Listen.
So, this may be one of probably
the most bizarre situations
I have ever been in
in my entire life.
Like, I've just been in the
middle of a (bleep) strip club,
eating chicken like, what the (bleep)
it's just (bleep) jokes.
But the chicken is (bleep) top, man.
Atlanta is a thumbs up from me.
Best (bleep) chicken wings I've ever had.
Let's (bleep) go, man.
Aah!
(upbeat music)
[Yungblud] So, this is
my date for the day.
How are you, sugar plum?
- Not bad.
- [Yungblud] Not bad?
- I'm hungry.
- I'm hungry too.
I'm starving.
I'm Hank bloody Marvin.
(laughing)
Let's go.
Ready?
Three.
Cheers.
(upbeat music)
- [Adam] How is it?
- It's like got so much (bleep) in it.
It's amazing.
Like normally, you just
have a hot dog with mustard.
But this has got like
everything to it, man.
It's got so many layers, and
I dunno mate, it's just (bleep) good.
I can't wait to try the
shake afterwards as well.
- [Giselle] And then
we just put the syrup,
we mix it, we blend it
with the vanilla mix.
- [Yungblud] Jesus.
It tastes like a (bleep) chocolate cake,
in like liquid form.
So I just had Portillo's
hot dog and cake shake.
10 out of 10 from me.
Made by the beautiful Giselle.
- [Adam] You haven't had deep dish yet.
- No, I've not had deep dish yet.
- [Adam] That's next.
- That's next.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Let's go.
So me and Adam are here in Chicago,
and we're gonna try deep dish pizza
for the very, very, very first time.
And I can't wait.
I'm excited.
Are you?
Scoop scoop.
- Hi, my name's Meggie,
and welcome to Lou Malnati's pizzaria,
home of Chicago's best deep
dish, Chicago style pizza.
(clanking)
- Look at that (bleep).
Man, it looks so big.
It's like an inch, man.
(upbeat music)
One more bite, man, one more bite.
That's it, honestly.
(upbeat music)
Another one.
(Bleep) me, man.
Who invented this (bleep)?
- [Man] How do you feel?
- Tired. (laughs)
Really damn tired.
- Alex is out to take the
(bleep) piece of pizza off of me
because I won't be able
to go on stage tonight
'cause I wanna keep eating it.
Take it away from me.
- One slice out, one's thrown up.
- [Yungblud] Yup. That's it.
(upbeat music)
Oh (bleep).
Aw, brain freeze, man.
Yo, so I'm at Snoasis, in
Baltimore, with the boys.
Ee.
There's like a beach on the ground.
Sick.
- Hi, my name is Erin,
we're here at Snoasis in Baltimore
and we have Snowballs
with finely shaved ice.
It's not ice cream, it's not custard,
but you can get ice cream on it.
- Look at this ice slime.
(playful music)
Yeah, it's (bleep) weird.
But insane.
(Bleep) man, that's good.
(playful music)
Is that chocolate snow stuff?
- [Erin] Yes.
- How do you even do that?
Man, this is sick.
I'm in, I'm (bleep) in.
I am like sugar rushing right now.
My head is like (screeching sound).
(unintelligible noises)
Sugar fuels me.
(yelling)
Don't give Dom sugar.
Big up to Baltimore.
Thank you for teaching me
the ways of the Snowball.
Me and the lads enjoyed
it very much, didn't we?
- Oh yeah, it's very nice.
- Very nice, very nice, very very nice.
I'm rushing off my nut right now on sugar.
I'm probably not gonna sleep,
so I'll check in at 3
o'clock this morning.
And I'll see ya later.
(yelling)
So, that's it man.
I'm literally speechless.
I've gained about ten stone, but whatever.
Thank you so much, America.
The food's been great.
Peace out.
(upbeat music playing)
- Hey guys, we're Pero Like.
- Do you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
- (speaking Spanish)
- For more Latino content.
- Subscribe here.
(upbeat music)